and almost like we planned it please
don't do that
Apple yeah ah don't do that don't send
don't do this all right all right thank
thanks so much for coming and and thanks
Sebastian its I was super cool I mean
just getting to see that data getting to
understand it this is this talk I guess
is sort of really oddly related to the
last two talks this talk is in essence
partly about figuring out or learning
how to think well about what might be
going on in auctions and ad exchanges
it's also partly thinking about how
using dynamic mechanisms like ascending
auctions can be useful because they
create good incentives for the
auctioneer
so the thought here some of you have
seen this paper before I've realized in
the many times I presented this I've
been unable to give a sort of cogent
human readable definition of an
ascending auction I'm making another
attempt this time please tell me if I'm
getting it at all right that would be
tremendously helpful okay so some of you
may be aware that there's been some some
controversy and ad exchanges to do with
how auctioneers set prices so up until
about the middle of last year second
price auctions were still reasonably
widespread in ad exchanges and there was
a view that these auctions had a
transparency problem now this is just a
quote from an industry newsletter the
claim that some bidders made is that the
auctioneers were letting the bids come
in claiming they were running a
second-price auction and then afterwards
choosing which price floor they wanted
in particular you could choose a price
floor that was the highest bid minus
Epsilon
now why can they get away with this well
it turns out that
in at exchanges the bidders are very
substantially anonymous to each other
right you bidding you bidding on an
individual impression don't know the
identities of the other bidders and you
receive very little feedback about
what's going on essentially you're told
whether or not you won the auction and
if you want you're told how much you pay
now this is not only a problem in online
auctions this has been a problem for a
long time you may be aware that there's
a practice called chandelier bidding
that is common in art auctions at South
reason Christie's and the thought is
that in a chandelier bidding scenario
the auctioneer is in the front of the
room and says I have a bid for $100,000
for this piece of art and no human being
has in fact placed a bid for a hundred
for a hundred thousand dollars now you
might ask why is this so like don't
people need to shout out their bids it
turns out that only happens in the
movies in real world art auctions for
the most part bidders arrange secret
bidding languages with the auctioneer
they say something like look if I touch
my ear that means I'm incrementing my
bid by $10,000 this is in these auction
formats it's really bad to have an itchy
ear so this is the New York Times report
it turns out that chandelier bidding is
not only permitted in art auctions it's
fully legal so New York City regulations
say that auctioneers are permitted to
fabricate bids up to the reserve price
of the item now itself appease and
Christie's the reserve price is secret
it's not listed in the catalog so in
effect this is a regulation with no bite
the auction is sought the bees on
Christie's can and in fact do make up
bids in these art auctions
so the dealers typically say look I
don't want to give away that I'm you
know if I'm a serious bidder and I've
done my research I don't want other
people to benefit off having done my
research therefore I want to hide that
it's me bidding so this is the one bit
of data I want to show you this shows
you for various categories of art
auctions at Christie's how the winning
bid was collected you can see that about
a quarter of the time in blue the
winning bid is from somebody who's
physically present in the room
bidding typically using one of these
secret bidding languages Christie's will
permit you to submit absentee bids free
of charge so Christie's will say to you
look just tell me your reservation value
for the item I will bid for you as
though you were in the room you can see
despite the fact that the service is
offered free it doesn't happen all of
the time
yellow our bids offered through
Christie's portal for internet bidding
over the internet read our bids that are
offered during the auction by phone so
in an hour auction these days you get
this quite hurried Bank of auction house
staffers at the front of the room they
are fielding calls from individual
bidders making representations to the
bidders about what's going on in the
room and potentially getting bids from
those bidders getting claims from those
bidders about how much they are willing
to pay okay so having gone really far
into the world I want to pull us back
into economic theory right economic
theory has a way to think about
incentives to play by the rules
in particular the idea of incentive
compatibility in essence is about the
idea that nobody should want to break
the rules of the mechanism incentive
compatibility requires that none of the
bidders should find it profitable to
cheat we're cheating is behavior that
can be made to look legal by
misrepresenting that participants
preferences with the proviso that those
fictitious preferences should be within
certain plausible limits and what do we
mean by those plausible limits those
plausible limits are typically encoded
in the type space right the type space
in a mechanism design model are the
Preferences that we think the
participants might plausibly have now in
many ways what we
want to do is to produce a definition of
auctioneer incentive compatibility that
runs in lockstep with her witch's
original motivation we are going to
require that the auctioneer should not
find it profitable to cheat we're
cheating is defined as behavior that can
be made to look legal by misrepresenting
the Preferences of the other bidders to
one of the bidders and we're going to
again require that the fictitious
preferences should be within certain
plausible limits namely those
represented by the type space so here's
the thought right in the second price
auction imagine you're running a second
price auction by telephone right you get
calls from the bidders saying here's my
bid here's my bid here's my bid b1 b2
and so on one thing you could do is you
could award the object to bidder one and
charge be one minus Epsilon right this
is exactly the deviation the people
allege that ad exchanges might have done
now this looks legal to bidder one why
because maybe bidder two's value was
literally just B 1 minus Epsilon
in which case you the auctioneer have
strictly increased your profit now this
is not a new observation victory in the
paper that invents the second price
auction observes that the auctioneer
would want to deviate and therefore
recommends that the auctioneer find some
disinterested third party to run the
auction on his behalf
now imagine you tried to do this same
thing in a first price auction so you're
in a first price auction you receive
these bids b1 b2 and so on now you're a
smart auctioneer you know we're playing
the fully separating symmetric
equilibrium so you invert bitter ones
bid to figure out her value then you
make a take-it-or-leave-it offer it to
bidder one of her value minus epsilon
you say well aha I know your value now
how about I sell you the object at your
value minus a penny now if this happens
probably bidder one brings a lawsuit and
she wins right she says hold on the
rules of this auction are that I pay my
bid not that I pay just any amount you
choose after I submit my bid so bidder
one detects that you've deviated and has
an incentive to
the police so this is again it turns out
there's nothing new Under the Sun this
is also not a new observation victory in
the paper then invents the second price
auction observes that the first price
auction is automatically self policing
in a way that the second price auction
is not and our contribution in this
paper is mostly to find a way to think
precisely about what it means for an
auction to be automatically self
policing so at a high level the standard
approach in auction theory is to say
that there's no room to misrepresent the
auctioneer is an automaton that takes in
the bids and outputs in allocation and
payments here we are going to permit the
auctioneer to misrepresent any bidders
action to any other bidder
so in some sense we're taking the
opposite and extreme assumption so we're
going to treat the auctioneer as a nexus
of communication
who makes private telephone calls to
each of the bidders but we assume that
there aren't public announcements and we
assume that the bidders can't confer
directly with each other then we're
gonna call we're gonna permit the
auctioneer to deviate with the proviso
that she can only do so in ways that
look legal to each of the bidders and
we're going to call an auction
incredible if it's incentive compatible
for the auctioneer to follow the rules
of the auction okay so make these
precise in a moment at a high level this
is what we have we're gonna look at the
useful benchmark model of independent
private values auctions they're gonna
look for regular iid values we're going
to give the auctioneer utility function
we're going to assume the auctioneer
wants revenue and we're going to
restrict attention to auctions in which
only the winning bidder
makes any payment we can relax that but
that will complicate the exposition now
in this world it's well known that there
is a unique static strategy proof
optimal auction optimal in the sense of
revenue maximizing right it's the second
price auction the green Lafond Holmstrom
theorem tells us essentially that this
is the only payment rule that is
compatible with these two properties
static meaning everybody simultaneously
kate's with the auctioneer strategy
proof in the sense that we've seen
earlier now a very natural question is
so I mean optimum that it maximizes the
expected revenue of the auctioneer so
this is a second price auction with a
Meyerson reserve
so second price auctions are not
credible by the definition it's very
natural task if there is a way to run a
credible auction that static that
proceeds only in one round and it turns
out there is and there is essentially
exactly one the first result of the
paper is that an auction is credible and
static even only if it's the first price
auction so the way you get around this
in the world of static auctions if you
want to make an auction credible if you
want it to be self-policing the thing
you need to do is you need it to be that
every bidder upon making their bid knows
exactly how much they pay if they win
that's a first price auction now that
immediately tells you that we face a
choice right we'd like to have these two
properties and in a static election we
can't have them both at once so a very
natural question is if we permitted the
auctioneer to adopt more complicated
communication protocols to in principle
convey information to the bidders at the
point where they're called to play and
to ask bidders for information gradually
is it possible to get both of these
properties at once and it turns out that
there is and there's in fact essentially
only one way to do so so the second
result is that an auction is credible
and strategy proof if and only if it's
an ascending auction and you should tell
me later on if I've managed to define
this in a way that's human readable but
essentially that gives you a trail image
here are three properties I don't want
to denigrate the use of static mechanism
static mechanisms are frequently vital
for logistical reasons right you can't
run an ad auction in an ad exchange that
proceeds in multiple steps because
you've got about 50 milliseconds in
which to decide who wins and how much
they pay and the speed of light
constraint prevents you from being able
to do hundreds of rounds of
communication right so these are all
three properties that might sometimes be
useful and we have a trilemma you can't
have all three you can have any two of
three and picking two of three in the
simple benchmark model pins down
entirely one of the standard auction
formats
oh yes this is this is just the green
Lafond Holmstrom theorem or
alternatively it's it's a corollary of
the Milgram Sigala envelope theorem
you know requiring strategy proof nests
entirely pins down the payment rule
using a standard argument okay so we're
gonna go to the benchmark model this is
obviously a lab it's not the world rail
auctions are much more complicated
symmetric independent private values
there's one object there's a set of
bidders denoted n with representative
element I only winning bidders make any
payments the outcome just specifies who
gets the object and how much they pay
the bidders have private values
quasi-linear utility so that's a utility
function UI their value theta I is iid
with some density we're gonna make the
usual assumptions that density is
continuous positive regular now I'm
gonna need a few more things to get this
going these are the new primitives I'm
gonna add an auctioneer utility function
u 0 for the auctioneer the auctioneer's
utility is just the revenue from an
outcome each bidder observes whether or
not he gets the object and how much he
pays that's an assumption natively about
the bidders physical ability to audit
the world the thought is that u in an
auction sort of necessarily know whether
or not you win the object right there's
not gonna be you know a Renoir painting
shows up in your living room and you
don't know why it got there and you kind
of physically know how much money is in
your wallet right we're not going to
allow the auctioneer to secretly pick
your pocket without you knowing it so
we're gonna impose those constraints but
we're not going to impose the constraint
that you know additionally how much the
other bidders are paying or whether or
not some other bidder got the object
yeah
we're going to allow the auctioneer to
make claims about this information and
it is going to be a question whether or
not the auctioneer would find it
incentive compatible to make these
claims correctly and truthfully right
right so one way to order the second
price auction right is to say cards on
the table I'm going to tell you exactly
how much everybody bid I'm gonna put up
a big list of everybody's names we're
attached to each name is the bid they
made and I'm gonna publicly announce you
know in the town square who won and how
much they paid right now our model is
abstracting from that kind of public
communication it's a good question why
this public communication of this form
is actually quite rare in practice for
instance it's not actually clear who
wins the auctions at Sotheby's right it
is in fact private the identity of the
winner and in fact auctioneers at
Sotheby's do not disclose for instance
the profile of absentee bids they
received neither in ad auctions are we
you know do auction is typically
disclose the profile of bids not least
because a lot of the bidders view that
their bid is the result of a lot of
proprietary data science of the kind you
saw earlier this morning and perhaps
leaking all of that information is
leaking something that's valuable to the
bidder all of that is outside our model
our model is incredibly simple and
abstracting from the possibility of
public communication even though as
Laura observes public communication is
an alternative way to order to mechanism
if we're willing to spill the beans and
what everybody did that is one more way
to make sure that the auctioneer can't
secretly cheat and you know we're going
to take it as given here that the
auctioneer can't publicly communicate
and leave sort of unmodeled the reasons
in the world why that might be so
kind of part of your mother when you
talk about ascending oh so that's a
subtlety the thing we prove is that the
ascending auction is incentive
compatible in this world even when you
are communicating with each bidder
privately over the telephone so we are
binding our hands there as well we're
not letting the auctioneer make some
sort of public oral announcement you
know you can imagine it's exactly like
those auction house staffers at the
front of the room
you said it's puzzling that there isn't
there is no public communication of that
sort the offic Librium in some sense if
the data is available and people could
sort of say I want to see it I'm
suspicious yeah
not seeing it does not say say that it's
not actually playing a role yes that's
true nonetheless I suspected if he went
to Christie's and you said I want to
know who won you know the road on last
week they would not be very receptive to
that request okay
yes totally totally I agree that's like
it is worthwhile to consider publicly
producing information now that's not a
cure all right because what I could do
is I could invent show bidders right who
insert bids at epsilon below this you
know the highest bid and that would even
if I were to publicize it I may not be
able to get caught because you know who
needs to know who the sheíll bidder is
so that wouldn't be a panacea but
certainly there is a sort of hidden
trade-off here between sort of audit
ability and privacy that our model is
ignoring and resolving just by saying
we're in a world of sort of total
privacy total private communication even
though it's undoubtedly important to
think about like what auctioneers should
make public and why and in what
circumstances and we don't have a lot of
work right now that gives us great ways
to think about that some of pealed war
checks work like pushes bravely in this
direction but I'm not going to make a
fool of myself trying to explain it
okay um as you might guess today is
extensive for Mechanism day G is gonna
denote an extensive form mechanism this
is just an extensive game form a game
tree of the usual kind except at
terminal histories instead of specifying
utilities specify an outcome they
specify who wins they specify how much
the winner pays I'm gonna restrict
attention to mechanisms with finite
depth with no chance moves and with
perfect recall that's to say you can't
Club bidders over the head to make them
forget what they've done a bitter
strategy in this world is a function
from information sets and types into
actions so it's as though we're
imagining the randomization over types
that happen before the initial node
everybody comes into the initial node
endowed with the private information
that is their type and a strategy just
tells me what they do as a function of
what they know both from within the game
and their private information their
value now I'm gonna be a little bit
unusual and analyze not just mechanisms
but protocols these are pairs consisting
of mechanisms and strategy profiles for
those mechanisms so this is in essence a
communication protocol that says what
each bidder should tell the auctioneer
as a function of what he's been told so
far and as a function of his own private
information right and what queries the
auctioneer is going to make to the
bidders in what order and what
information if any of the auctioneer
will provide at the point of making each
query now these are a few further
restrictions that just serve to clean up
the definitions I'm going to assume that
for every history there's a type profile
that puts that history on the path of
play so the game tree has no Deadwood
I'm going to assume every information
set has at least two actions so if
you're called to play you'll make a real
choice and we're called to play at some
history you can affect the outcome these
are all without loss of generality in
the sense that if there's a protocol
that doesn't satisfy these restrictions
that gets me what I like I can prune
away these things to produce a protocol
does satisfy these restrictions that
gets me what I like I'm gonna restrict
attention to measurable protocols that
just means that the interim expected
revenue interim expected utility and so
on are well defined in the usual way
okay so this is the simplest second
price auction bitter one bids five or
ten two without observing one's action
bids five or 15 now suppose we're the
auctioneer the rules say we call it
bitter one one and we say one do you
want to bid five or ten and one says
okay I'll bid five so we put down the
phone we call it bitter two and we say -
do you want to bid five or 15 and two
says ok I'll bid fifteen now the rules
of the game say this is the outcome
right two wins and pays five but you
like money so what you do is you give
the object to bidder - and you charge
him ten
notice both bidders can come away
thinking you followed the rules one says
I bid five and I didn't win okay that
just means that two well bid me who says
I bid 15 and I paid ten okay that just
means that one bid ten so both players
come away thinking you followed the
rules so we're gonna take this thought
and just formalize it as a game that
includes the auctioneer so this is a
messaging game that sort of embeds
within it a communication protocol so at
the start the auctioneer can either
choose an outcome and end the game or go
to step two in step two the auctioneer
chooses some agent and sends a message
where a message is just an information
set for that player in the original game
right so we've got some mechanism we've
got some protocol the auctioneer has
promised to run the auctioneer sends a
message that corresponds to an
information set in that protocol their
agent privately observes the message and
chooses a reply and what's a reply well
as just one of the actions available at
that information set in the original
mechanism the auctioneer privately
observes the reply and we go back to
step one
so it should be clear if you give me any
extensive game form right there is a
rule following auctioneer strategy right
I can start from the initial history
send a message to who I meant to
communicate from the replies update the
history correctly send a message to the
next person and so on and so on and when
I hit the terminal history choose the
corresponding outcome so the full
commitment paradigm just says the
auctioneer is committed to like an
automaton do this right the auctioneer
strategy that runs the mechanism G our
partial commitment paradigm says the
auctioneer can deviate to any strategy
that an individual agent cannot
distinguish from the rule-following
strategy and this is what we mean by
that so the auctioneer has promised some
protocol and there's some auctioneer
strategy that plays by the rules that
runs the mechanism what does I observe
while I is going to observe a
communication sequence consisting of
messages to player I and the replies
that I sent
and eventually the auctioneer is gonna
choose an outcome so the eye is gonna
observe whether or not he wins and how
much he pays so let's denote that
observation
oh I which depends on the auctioneer
strategy the agent strategy profile and
the type profile I'm going to say that
an observation has an innocent
explanation if it's consistent with the
conjecture that the auctioneer is
following the rules that's to say there
exist types for the other agents such as
the observation that I actually has is
the same as the observation that I would
have if the auctioneer was playing by
the rules but the other agents had those
types so this is behavior that can be
milk made to look legal to each bidder
by a misrepresentation of the other
bidders preferences
and then gonna call a strategy safe if
for all bidders and all type profiles
that bidders observation has an innocent
explanation
and then as you might expect a protocol
is credible if following the rules is a
best response to the agents assigned
strategies that's the save it yields at
least as much expected utility as any
safe deviation cool okay so this is that
right one bid five two-bit fifteen we
charge to ten dollars instead of five
dollars that's the innocent explanation
for bitter one bitter one says well
what's the explanation for my not
winning twos type was fifteen she says
what's the explanation for my paying ten
the innocent explanation is that one's
type was ten so this is a safe deviation
now know that this is in principle we
are allowing not just for the auctioneer
to choose different outcomes at the end
of the game but to deviate even Midway
the auctioneer can send false messages
during the mechanism she's allowed to
adopt any communication strategy that is
safe and in particular that means that
she needs to be careful that whatever
messages she sends she can wrap up in a
way such that at every type profile
every agent sees something that has an
innocent explanation
okay there's a related literature
there's which are mostly skip but this
is probably this 2015 aar paper is
probably the closest to ours their
definition is a lot like our definition
but restricted to revelation mechanisms
now for their setting I think this is
without loss of generality but for our
setting this restriction does lose some
generality so we're going to allow
extensive foreign mechanisms we're going
to allow multistage communication
okay so now we're going to move to the
benchmark auction laboratory a protocol
is optimal a bit maximizes revenue
subject to be IC and participation
constraints it's static if every agent
has one information set and is always
called to play now this is a definition
of a first price auction it's a little
bit weird but it's not super weird
essentially a protocol is a first price
auction if it's static and each bidder
choses some bid from a feasible set of
real numbers or declines the player with
the highest bid wins and pays his bid
now notice that in stating this I'm
allowing myself to set a reserve right a
reserve is just restricting the feasible
set B I write a reserve of a hundred is
just nobody can make B I only includes
numbers above a hundred
notice the bids are defined here by
their consequences not by their labels
right so if we're running an auction
where you know the bids are numbered 100
200 300 and the agreement is the highest
bid wins and you pay half your bid
that's the first price auction by our
definition because by our definition the
meaning of a bid is that it is the
amount that you will pay if you win
after having taken that action
okay so yes but it's also the amount
when you are evaluating what's highest
yes yes yes so those are the dual
meanings of the bid they so in some
sense we think this is the
mathematically right way to think about
a bid right a way that's label invariant
right the important thing is that you
know especially as we've been getting
into framing this afternoon
right if I reframe a first price auction
by expressing bids in some other
language it remains a first price
auction right because the important
thing about a first price auction is the
person who wins each each action is
associated with an amount you will pay
if you win and the person who wins is
the person who plays the action with the
highest associated amount and if you
think this is completely natural I'm
completely onboard with you
theorem one says this is exactly what
you need for the characterization assume
the protocol is optimal if it's the
first price auction it's credible and
static if it's credible and static then
it's almost everywhere a first price
auction by almost everywhere I mean that
this description must be correct except
for a measure 0 set in the type space
well so all I'm saying is that in
defining a first price auction I'm
defining it using the consequences of
the bids and not the labels we choose so
so the thought the thought is each of
your actions has a number associated
with it right and there is weight
associate to each of your actions a
number with the property that if you win
you pay that number and the winner has
the highest number of all the numbers
submitted yes yes yes I mean I don't
think it is it's possible here that
we're all entirely on the same page so
first price auctions are credible and
Static that much is hopefully by
inspection right everybody submits their
bids every safe deviation charges
somebody their bid what's the best thing
to do charge the highest bid
why that's credible and static implied
that there is it's almost everywhere
first price well suppose after you play
an action there are two prices that you
might pay well here's a profitable safe
deviation the auctioneer should charge
to deviate to charge you the higher of
the two prices therefore for each of
your actions there must be a unique
price that you will pay if you win right
which gives you a lot of the structure
of the first price auction now this is a
little bit too simple the real proof
must ensure that the deviation is
measurable and there's a little bit of
technicality used to do that but this is
the core of the idea so you can prove
that almost everywhere for each action
that you take there's a unique price you
pay if you win whereupon we're entirely
in standard terrain the optimal
allocation is pinned down by Meyerson
the envelope theorem pins down payments
almost everywhere so the winning bidder
has the highest bid QED
okay by-the-bye as we were saying
earlier this morning ad exchanges are
switching from second price auctions the
first price based at least partially on
concerns that the auctioneers are
cheating so nowadays a lot of display
advertising is you know it has either
switched recently or is in the process
of being switched to first price
auctions
alright so now I'm gonna try to fill in
this last bit of the trilemma strategy
proof you know we've also been at this
all afternoon a protocol is strategy
proof if for every bitter that bidders
for all opponent strategies that bitter
strategy is a best response the goal is
the characterize the sort of optimal
extensive game forms that are both
credible and strategy proof the problem
is that there's no revelation principle
right
the auctioneer could make any queries in
any order the agents could receive
information when they're called to play
there's a further technical problem
which is that the entire machinery of
extensive game forums moves in discrete
steps right and if I give you a discrete
extensive clock auction that auction
can't be exactly optimal so I'm gonna
need to do something to avoid that what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna just
discretize the distribution and
hopefully what we see is not you know
it's a fairly inoffensive discretization
this will mean that ascending auctions
can in principle be optimal and so can
many other protocols for instance I
could just run you know in fact I can
get a lot of other examples from
Sebastian's talk to pact would be
optimal to pack B would be optimal an
auction where you you know a sealed bid
auction would be optimal you know an
auction where I queried you from the top
asking you is your value 100 or lower
ninety-nine or lower and so on and then
process this via second price rules
would also be optimal
so I'm going to discretize the
distribution by splitting the type space
up into a grid and have some iid
probability mass function defined on
that grid epsilon is just the gap
between adjacent grid spaces you can
make that as small as you like I'm gonna
define a pseudo PDF which is just a
probability or
add a grid point divided by the step of
the grid I'm gonna define a CDF in usual
way and a virtual value which is
hopefully familiar to everybody here it
turns out that everything you know about
virtual values from the continuous case
applies essentially in the discrete case
and if anything is off it's off by no
more than epsilon where epsilon is the
grid increment so I'm gonna assume as
usual that the virtual values are
regular that's to say that this function
is strictly increasing
I'm also gonna need to deal with ties
and just for technical convenience what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna assume
essentially that if David and I are such
that whenever our bids are tied David
wins so if our bids are tied at 50 and
David wins that means that if our bids
were tied at 60 David would also win so
an auction is orderly if for some
reserve row and some strict order on the
bidders bidder I wins the object even
only if his type is above the reserve
and for all other bidders his type is
more than that bidders type where we
break ties using this fixed high
breaking order ties can become really
unlikely if you take epsilon small but
we need to deal with them somehow okay
so with all that setup this I assert is
a credible strategy proof auction start
of the auction I don't know what each
bidders type is so they could be
anywhere
red and blue I set an optimal reserve
using the usual formula I call up red
and I say hey red will you bid the
reserve and red says sure then I call up
blue and I say hey blue will you bid the
reserve and blue says sure then I call
up red and I say red Blue has matched
your bid will you raise your bid by
Epsilon red says sure I go back to blue
blue says sure and so on and so on now
eventually I call blue to say will you
raise your bid and blue says no blue has
quit this is exactly his type what's
gonna happen well red will pay the least
type associated with his bid so far
that's to say that's his payment right
that was his last bid he's now won
that's his payment you notice that like
a first price auction at any point if
this protocol ends without me querying
you further you know exactly how much
you're going to pay and that it turns
out is key to make the protocol credible
now a natural question is why not
chandelier bid because it is permissible
right a chandelier bid is in our model a
safe deviation why not raise ones price
by Epsilon
falsely claiming to was still in the
auction and the answer is you don't want
to do that because one's virtual value
is positive so one's bid be one why not
ask him to bid be one plus Epsilon
well the rules require that one pay be
one what would happen if we chandelier
bid by Epsilon this is the probability
that one's type is exactly b1 well if
its type is exactly b1 doing this means
he quits and that means we can't make
any revenue safely so we lose b1 on the
other hand this is a probability as type
is strictly above b1 if we do that
successfully then we raise revenue by
Epsilon but this should look familiar
divided through and we've just got the
negative of the virtual value it turns
out that the virtual value is the
expected loss from chandelier bidding by
epsilon and so because we're above the
optimal reserve it's not profitable to
chandelier bid now this is not quite a
proof because we actually do need to
deal with a much richer class of
deviations you don't just randomly a bit
by epsilon in principle you could handle
a bit by more than epsilon or you could
hold a bitter and reserve and run the
other bidders against each other you
know keeping this bidder in your back
pocket the rail proof can in principle
deal with that but I'm just gonna try to
give you the generalization of that two
bit of protocol I just showed you
because this is the thing that
characterizes credible strategy proof
mechanisms in general so protocol is an
ascending option if I'm gonna start by
describing sort of global properties
that don't have directly to do with the
game tree if the induced allocation is
orderly and the induced payment rule has
threshold pricing what do I mean by that
I mean that each bidder pays the lowest
type he could have reported while still
winning the object so if you don't if
you don't win you pay nothing if you win
you pay an amount equal to the lowest
type you could have reported while still
winning the odd
these are joint restrictions on the
mechanism and the strategy profile now
I'm going to describe the extensive game
form the extensive game form works like
this each bidder has an initial bid
equal to zero and at each non-terminal
history some bidder is called to play
and has offered a set of prices where
all the prices are at least his current
bid so this is an ascending auction in
the proper sense the available actions
either accept one of the offered prices
or quit if you quit you're not called to
play again you do not win and you pay
zero if you accept some price P then we
update your bid to P I'm gonna
additionally require that H information
set there is typically a unique price
offer and a unique accepting action
let's say there's only one way you can
go forward while still keeping in the
auction typically is because in some
circumstances if you're the unique
active bidder left and you haven't yet
been the reserved I can give you
multiple ways to multiple actions that
bid the reserve without changing
credibility but for the most part in the
game tree it's fine if you think of this
as being unique and at each terminal
history the winner pays whatever his
latest bid is so like a first price
auction you pay the last bid you placed
if you win
okay so that's a class of game trees it
turns out that's the whole class assume
the protocol is optimal and orderly it's
credible and strategy proof even only if
it's an ascending auction
and that gives us the trilemma
and pretty much the rest of the
conclusion is faff so I'm not going to
go through that path but the core
thought is this right the core thought
is that ascending auctions hide
information they hide information
because when you bid a hundred in an
ascending auction all that the
auctioneer learns is that your value is
greater than or equal to 100 that makes
it risky for the auctioneer to cheat
because when the auctioneer cheats she
runs the risk that you quit and it turns
out that in the simple Meyerson model
that risk is exactly enough to make sure
that the auctioneer stays on the
straight and narrow to make it incentive
compatible for the auctioneer to follow
the rules now there are many important
desert errata that our model leaves out
like the possibility of public
communication like the possibility that
values are you know interdependent or
affiliated and all of those are
important but we think it's kind of neat
that you know in some sense these three
atomic auctions can be characterized in
terms of three simple properties and
that they give us a way to think of
trade-offs between the logistics of
running the auction giving good
incentives to the bidders and giving
good incentives to the auction yes yes
yes and absolutely right one reason why
you can't run ascending auctions over
the internet right is that if you're
doing something in an ad exchange and
you communicate a hundred times you
losing 15 milliseconds each time because
of the speed of light that person has
moved on to another page right that's a
real logistical constraint
yep so it's pretty critical that the
decision for Meghan to quit is there a
vocable yes otherwise an auctioneer can
put in a chandelier bid realize that it
is failed and then come back down and
yes better to re-enter absolutely is it
the case that you lose credibility
altogether even in first price options
if there's that sort of behavior and
then this that sort of behavior observed
in our auctions so I guess there are two
things to say one is that the
characterization theorem says that were
you to make quitting revocable the
auction would not be credible right the
fact that quitting is irrevocable is key
to making the protocol credible the
second thing is that in fact that is the
one part where the RET where the New
York City regulations have bite if the
object is bought by the house the
regulations require the auctioneer to
represent afterwards that it has been
bought by the house and the auction
houses themselves say if we've bought
something by the house so a chandelier
bidder has won the auction that object
is burnt in the sense that we will not
offer it for sale for a period of at
least several years so there are some
things that do help make these less
revocable out there in the world
so some bidders are very unhappy with
chandelier bids but typically not the
experienced bidders the experienced
bidders understand chandelier bids may
be there and in fact in our model
chandelier bids would just be one more
one more way of enforcing a reserved
right it would be incentive compatible
to chandelier bid up to reserve but no
further so ironically the New York City
regulation which I'm sure was not built
with game theory in mind is exactly the
thing that would have been incentive
compatible namely that you're allowed to
place Chandler bids up to the optimal
reserve
[Applause]